I am back again it's Sunday it's 4:10
p.m. I think I'll have time for one game
this is a a ten minute rapid arena and
there's just under 20 minutes left in
the tournament so I'll try in place in
the top 500 I think that's a reasonable
goal okay I'm playing Eve on camera
layeth I'm feeling feeling aggressive
I'm gonna play oh never mind he's he's
feeling more aggressive I wanted to play
the Stafford gambit but now we have a
Kings gambit let's play this line this
is a so-called [ __ ] your counter gambit
but that would involve efore I'm gonna
take on f4 I think there's a name for
this but I forget it it's like the Basia
variation we just probably knows um so
c4 is a a move I think the idea is to
play c6 and then you know I will say I
don't know too much fury here I assume I
should take and then white takes back
the other move is Bishop d6 the bishop
t65 could be troublesome because hen d6
comes so let's take hello to people in
the chat I'm not gonna say hello to
everyone specifically but I'll just
acknowledge your existence I think it's
time to develop Bishop to b4 in 96 ship
somewhere it's all these different
possibilities covert with Assad thanks
Kover maybe Bishop b4 and then castling
looks very reasonable because the king
is still in the center for white and if
I can Castle and play rook e8 could be
nice
in most openings I want to say this is
like a universal principle but most of
the time you should develop your keen
side before the queenside and that's
what I'm doing here I haven't touched
anything on the queenside in terms of
pieces okay so let's castle one of the
issues for whites is that let's say he
plays Bishop e2 then I can take on c4 if
he takes back with Bishop then rookie it
comes with tempo if he doesn't play
Bishop e2 then rook e8 will still come
with tempo I'm getting a call oh no I
think I scheduled a meeting off to call
this person back I have to finish this
game this might be a quick stream
I might have only only time for one game
but that's okay my last dream I also
only played one game and it made for a
great YouTube video is like perfectly
there's like 20 25 minutes there's some
nice analysis some nice checkmates okay
so I'm not gonna take too much time this
is what I was just thinking beforehand I
mean it might be that white will Castle
here and then okay so I wants to take
you're next so I think Bishop e6 is
reasonable it's defending the pawn if
you plays Queen a4 I can play 96 to
follow up defend it's
for potential problems should be six
let's do it
don't see anything too wrong with this
okay hello to people who are saying
hello hello Anton Sal
hello Leto hello Bucci aunty
hello kbh Khan or KB Khan whatever your
name is me flying toasters hello okay so
he's pinning the Knights to the Queen
Bishop e7 is the first move that comes
to mind what's really solid this is a
move that can run into this but then I
had this 97 looks reasonable
looks very reasonable because I want to
reinforce my knight so my queen will
then have a bit more mobility in Queen
b6 isn't very nice square pressure the
diagonal pressure the pawn
it's from sarony Leo thinks Sarah Nellie
Oh am I taking challenges oh no I'm not
if you want to play me you'd have to go
back in time and somehow be this guy but
I'll do future streams were all take
challenges it's just my schedule is a
bit tight today hello - Juan JC egg okay
so time is
pleasant position as pleasant I have a
general idea of what I'm doing next
like Queen musics rook c8 rooks can come
into the center and this is actually an
isolated pawn
it's a passed pawn but it's a potential
weakness 90 for aggressive I'm really
tempted to just take it I have two minor
pieces for a queen then I'd be down
material and now Queen b6 looks less
attractive because then he takes twice
and doubles my pawns so maybe now Bishop
e7 and we could trade but that should be
helpful it's really up to white to prove
something here how he's gonna get
compensation because if I hold on to
this fawn it's a nice bowl nice pawn to
hold on to
maybe someday I'll play b5 very soon
actually what time is it where you are
from at the very beginning of the stream
I said it was for 10 p.m. now it's for
18 p.m. so my uptime is probably like 8
or 9 minutes I'll have to check the
theory of this afterwards climate
entirely sure what he did wrong because
it already looked unpleasant for him
after i castled but maybe there's some
theory I'm not aware of it's 20 to 18 in
Germany that's what that's 10 p.m.
that's 10:18 p.m. what is my feed a
classical raining
I don't even want to check I've dropped
so many fidei points in the last like
two years I peaked at 24 25 in 2015 and
then my rating just like plunged now
it's like 23
I hope it's about 23 40 it should be
it's very far away from reaching the
2500 pinnacle that's the next like
milestone it's like this GM requirement
it's taking a long time on that move
probably for a good reason
92 okay so he wants to run upon I could
defend the pond a 4 a 6
I mean pawns like to be defended by
other pawns so yeah let's play d5 I'll
create a pawn chain if you plays a 4 ok
King h1 King h1 is very normal move when
the player is missing in a spawn so i'm
tempted just to like trade right away
like Knight d5 then if we trade bishops
I'm threatening 93 let's do it and in
the meantime I'm just controlling the
center also there's no increment which
actually kind of changed as a strategy
because I just want to like keep all the
tension keep building up pressure and
then when he gets low on time I'll have
I'll have some flying potential he'll to
toilet noggin what's up Toyota noggin
thanks for the game earlier
I fled many games earlier I was checking
like Miley chess game counts I'm about
to reach 10,000 I'm afraid that I'm
gonna play my 10,000th game and not
realize it it's gonna happen maybe by
the end of the year even so if people
can just monitor that I think I'm let's
say that like 9800 or something
oh that messed up everything I need
opening a new tab I set up huh
[ __ ] this up okay Queen c1 so he doesn't
want to get forked which is
understandable I'm 93
I mean 93 looks pretty but I don't know
if it does anything he plays rook e1 I
tie Knight g4 would like something a bit
more purposeful I play Knight 7 f6 but
then he plays 95
she looks reasonable I have 695 I'm
gonna start with rook c8 there is a
general rule when it comes to rooks they
like to be on the same file as the
opponent's Queen like even if the file
is closed it might open up some day like
I might want to play c3 at some points
and I'll make him think okay so he's
stopping c3 he was a knight to the
center but the night's not defended and
it's aligned with my queen
like his might and bishop are no no
longer that's safe I could just play
Bishop f5 the knight g3 so maybe Bishop
to g4 yeah I'm just building a pressure
I like the alignment some nice x-ray
vision in various directions nine of
four could happen knife f4 speaking of
knife f4 shout out to Karen in the chats
hard to get to 2500 since I'm fine
yeah I've devoted my energy to other
things but thanks Karen for the comment
and shout out to Ben Feingold for
providing us with this amazing amazing
phrase knife f4 isn't there an emotes
there's like a knife there's a knife f5
emote right from Ben's dream hey he's
gonna get Forks
it was only a matter of time this night
sauna a great square oh I could have
pinned to forgot about Bishop f5 oh it's
funny cuz okay the Queen has to move to
b1 and then I might have to or I might
want to play Bishop f5 rather than
taking the brook or no Queen b1 I'll
take the rook after Bishop takes back
Bishop f5
life is good fine
hey and Karan's now a sub gifted by
toilet noggin welcome to the newest sub
92 so so there's a phrase it might sound
inappropriate um but I've heard it like
I heard it from another chess coach who
like teaches young kids and the phrase
is pee pee on the pee pee and each P
stands for something means put pressure
on the pinned piece and that's what
you're supposed to do when you're
pinning a piece not to capture it but to
pressure it after rook e8 there's enough
pressure to win it
now although mod is blocking blocking
certain comments okay let's take the
knight and win more material how much
material I'm just up a rook and a pawn
sometimes that's what happens like when
the positions difficult it was just like
a downward spiral he was he lost upon
early
probably because he played a dubious
gambit okay um let's go to analysis
board because I'll admit I I don't know
too much theory I just know ideas
so let's prefer inline notation
okay so e4 so if anyone plays a five is
black and you don't know what to play
against King's gambit
I can recommend d5 I think it's a simple
line to play trade and then nine f3 so
this is all very standard yeah let's
stay on the Masters database it's been
played before
Carlson played this wait what did
Carlson play the Kings gambit guess it
just kind of equalize interesting I
guess Carlsen I mean he can pretty much
play anything
okay so c4 c4 is a move but I guess if
you're playing the sine is white you
should play like Carlsen like Bishop c4
it's a better developing move Archer ATL
chess Archer I don't think we've ever
met in real life but I've I know who you
are because I see pictures on Facebook
posted by
so okay c4
the problem with this move it's just
kind of slow to develop and essentially
what happened was why it was
overextended that's funny my this pawn
was a beast it took this pawn and then
this pawn and I never ended up losing it
he plays d4 so he won the F pawn so was
a mistake
see for this is all mainline a c5 c5 is
actually a logical to restrict this
Bishop then I can't quickly play like
Bishop b4 castle and rook e8 with so
many Tempe b6 looks normal here but
that's a novelty but why well maybe
Bishop b5 check
well Bishop b5 check could be painful
within Bishop d7 I'm just gonna cheat I
want to see is there anything wrong with
this
what's with the settings usually I have
like three lines oh there we go
because I'm using Safari I haven't
changed the settings here yet
let's b6 the best move hey I have a
novelty if I play this again this is a
mainline so this could happen b6 is a
novelty at least according to the the
masters database and it's logical I
think if it works so okay he took take a
check hc3
castle and yeah Locke is scoring well
after Bishop e2 anything better for
whites it's already preferable for luck
I feel like it didn't really require
anything too special this game was just
like developing winning upon defending
the pond and then tactics yeah I usually
don't like to rely on sock fish I used
to use it more and like other engines
but it makes me lazy if I just have
stock fish turned on and I can keep
pressing spacebar to see like the
a variation just much rather use my
brain than the engine so this is called
the abbaseya variation it's probably one
of the very first openings in
alphabetical order wouldn't be able to
think of a opening that comes before
this anyway that was okay I was a
relatively short game I think I'll end
it here at least I'll end it here for
the YouTube audience cuz I'll I'll
probably put this on youtube if anyone
has any suggestions in the chat for like
a potential name for this video let me
know because I usually try and come up
with something some clever title that's
like intriguing but not necessarily
clickbait so let me know and yeah for
the twitch audience who's still watching
actually wait did I say bye to the
YouTube audience okay for the YouTube
audience PI and I'll see you in the
future
whatever in the future videos